so what we're going to try to do in this
video is add 7 tenths to 13 hundredths
pause this video and see if you can
figure what that is
all right so this might be a little bit
intimidating at first because we're
adding tenths here seven tenths and
we're adding hundredths here thirteen
hundredths how do i add a certain number
of tenths to a certain number of
hundredths and the key idea is to
re-express seven tenths as a certain
number of hundredths so how do we do
that well let's just first visualize
each of these fractions
so seven tenths if we imagine this
square is a whole and that we've divided
into ten equal sections i tried to hand
draw it as best as i can notice i have
filled in seven of those ten equal
sections that we have split the hole
into so this represents seven tenths and
thirteen hundredths
you could split the whole into a hundred
equal sections and i try to hand draw it
so assume that these are a hundred equal
sections and so notice this is a ten by
ten square and so you're going to have a
hundred of these squares and notice we
have ten plus three thirteen filled in
so we want to add d seven tenths to
these thirteen hundredths
now how do we express seven tenths in
terms of hundreds well visually you
could take each of your tenths and split
them into ten equal sections
now
you have your whole split into
hundredths and each of your tenths is
now
a hundredth so you have 10 times as many
things in the denominator and you also
have 10 times as many things
in the numerator before you had seven of
the tenths filled in
now you have 70 of the hundredths filled
in or another way to think about it we
multiplied the numerator by 10 and we
multiplied the denominator by 10. and if
you do the same thing to the numerator
and the denominator you multiply it or
divide it by the same number you're not
changing the value think about it 10
over 10 is the same thing as 1. so we're
just taking 1 and multiplying it by 7 10
isn't going to change the value
but this is as we've already talked
about this is equivalent to
70 over 100 so this is equal to 70
hundredths
which is this right over here plus 13
plus
13 hundredths
well now we're adding hundredths in both
cases if i have 70 of something and i
add to that 13 of the same somethings in
this case the something is hundredths
i'm going to have 83 of that thing so
this is going to be
70 let me do that same color
this is going to be equal to
70 plus 13
plus
13 hundredths
70 plus 13 hundredths and what's 70 plus
13 well that of course is going to be 83
hundredths
and
we are done